in the last video we left off with the
assassination of franz ferdinand
archduke franz ferdinand of australia
the heir to the austro-hungarian empire
and so you could imagine the
austro-hungarian empire did not take
that well they already did not
enjoy the kingdom of serbia trying to
essentially provoke this nationalistic
movement and they viewed them as this
small little weak country right below
them and so they use this to essentially
issue an ultimatum since you say look
immediately bring all the people who did
this to justice all the people who might
have conspired with the gavrilo princips
to create to allow this assassination
attempt to occur and if and and do it or
else and accept full responsibility and
actually the serbians were the kingdom
of serbia was in no mean was no no mood
to get into a war with austria-hungary
and so they tried their best to comply
but their best wasn't enough so then
july
28th a month later you have the
austrians declaring war on the serbians
austria
declares war
declares
war
on serbia now up until this point
austria the austro-hungarian empire is
thinking okay serbia is a small little
kingdom here it has some ties and
obviously it's a slavic nation so it has
some linguistic ties with the russian
empire the russian empire also had some
political ties to it but russia's not
going to get into a war with us over
this we're justified in attacking them
they've just killed the heir to our
throne so we're going to go in there and
russia is probably not interested in
actually creating a larger a larger
skirmish year
that was a severe miscalculation on the
part of the russian on the part of the
austrians the russians were not happy
about this they felt close ties to the
serbians and they felt a need to protect
the serbians or you could argue that
maybe they were they were they wanted to
mobilize just to scare the austrians
whatever it might be whether it was
russia wanted to get into a war whether
they were really looking to protect the
serbians or whether they were looking to
mobilize to scare the austrians from
actually attacking the russians began to
mobilize so the
russians began to gather their troops
so the russians
russians mobilize
mobilize and now this is where all of
the alliances start to come into effect
if you go if you remember about the
alliances we talked about several videos
ago
if you go to
1879 you have the dual alliance treaty
between germany and austria-hungary to
protect each other if russia attacks and
actually if russia attacks or mobilizes
so now germany's like hey maybe i am
obligated to protect austria-hungary
from russia you also have to remember in
1892
the franco-russian military convention
military assistance both ways in the
atten in the event of attack so
germany's thinking look you know we
signed this treaty and we to some degree
are maybe eager for war because we've
been militarizing so much
and i can't just fight russia i also
know that france and russia have this
alliance right over here so germany in
quite surprising quickness decides to
declare war on both so on august 1st
on august 1st germany declares war on
russia
on
russia
on russia and then on august
and then on august 3rd
august
august 3rd
germany declares war on france because
they know or at least they feel that
they can't declare war and only one of
them and they wanted to do it very
quickly because they didn't want russia
a chance to mobilize too much and the
fact that they were able to do this so
quickly i mean we're talking three was
this is three days after austria
declares war on serbia and then another
two days to declare war in france kind
of shows that germany was already in a
war footing it's not a joke to all of a
sudden invade to or declare war on
countries so germany was essentially
preparing for this and this this right
over here gave them the excuse to
essentially declare
war so they declare war on both of these
characters germany against russia
germany's declaring war on france now
the easiest way for them to move into
france so they're literally going on the
offense here is for them to go through
belgium is for them
is for them to go through belgium but
the germans were aware they're aware
that there's this 75 year old treaty the
treaty of london in 1839 article 7 said
that britain was to protect the
neutrality of belgium and germany was in
no interest to get into a war with the
british the british had a powerful
military especially a very powerful a
very powerful navy the germans said hey
let's just take on the russians and the
french from now for now and so they
actually reached out to the british and
said hey you know this little treaty
that you got here from 1839 this 75 year
old treaty you don't really take this
seriously right i mean if we have to go
through belgium you're not really going
to kind of hold hold true to this treaty
and and the british said no we we
actually take that very seriously
obviously the british had didn't want
the germans to be aggressive here the
the british didn't want the germans to
be able to invade france and so when in
august
in august 4 on august 4th
august
4th when germany essentially rolls
through belgium germany invades belgium
to get to
to get to france this gave the legal
justification for the british to declare
war on germany
a british
british
declare
war
on
germany and so in a matter of only i
mean not even i mean we're talking a few
months here from the assassination of
franz ferdinand of austria you
essentially have all of the major powers
of europe and then as we'll see because
they had these empires in in not too
long most of the world is at war with
each other